how do you think about recovery what are
the pillars of recovery that you think
are important and what are some things
that perhaps a lot of athletes out there
spend a lot of time thinking about uh
that maybe are less important sleep
nutrition obviously is extremely
important we don't believe very much in
supplementation or things like I'm again
I'm very demand oriented meaning that if
you take a supplement it should be
because you have a doctor or somebody
have identified that there you are
lacking something here and you will try
to compensate it by for example go to
altitude use iron supplementation if you
live in the nordics you're alone in
vitamin D okay try to supplement with
vitamin D and C if it make a change
calories is super important sleep is
super important but also being in a
place where you are able to recover
mentally to is very important and I
think that in the end it boils down to
choices if you really want to excel you
prioritize it
otherwise you're cheating yourself